the Mojo programming language combines
the usability of python with the
performance of C it's basically an
enhanced version of python specifically
designed for artificial intelligence
developers in this course Elliott
Arledge will teach you how to use Mojo
Ellie has created many popular courses
related to Ai and he's the perfect
person to teach this course let's start
learning welcome
to intro to the Mojo programming
language
course you're going to learn the
fundamentals of using Mojo you're going
to learn some of the intermediate and
advanced features of it as well
but before I touch on those
I should cover some Basics first so you
might be wondering who the heck is this
guy on your screen
well my name is Elliot I'm a computer
science student a computer science
student undergraduate and I like to mess
around with code I like to train
language models in my free time and I
build awesome content like this
so if you end up enjoying this feel free
to subscribe my YouTube channel is just
in the link in the description so you
can totally check that out if you want
uh a little disclaimer Mojo's a very new
programming language it was actually
released a week or two ago and by the
time you're seeing this this course may
actually be out of date so a little
disclaimer there uh there there might be
some new features there might be some
weird syntactical things that don't work
the same but this is to cover right now
there may be some new tutorials that
come out in the next you know little few
months here or maybe even the upcoming
years
so just a little disclaimer
this may be out of day by the time
you're watching this this video is
uploaded in September of 2023
so a little discommer there the docs
specifically the Mojo docs the Mojo
documentation says that this language is
actually designed for experience systems
programmers but the point of this course
is to provide you with the fundamentals
of getting using Mojo and being able to
easily bounce off the documentation when
needed so it assumes some fundamental
knowledge of simple languages like
python uh if you don't have any
programming experience I recommend you
touch on python a little bit or you
could even just chat GPT your way
through it that's what a lot of people
do in fact that's what I did to learn a
lot of what I know now
uh understanding a programming language
in depth will help you adapt to other
languages as well so if you have some
knowledge from ABC or C plus plus
or JavaScript or python this course will
just be even more easy for you to
understand
uh we're not going to be doing any
intensive projects we're just going to
explain how the language and the Mojo
command line interface works so we're
going to be building some simple scripts
we're going to be building Jupiter
notebooks using the Mojo language and
we're going to be doing some command
line stuff too
this materials only backtested on
Windows all you really need is a Linux
terminal like Ubuntu and everything is
the same
so this means if you're on a Macbook for
example you could search up a little
tutorial on YouTube for how to install
Ubuntu and get that set up but anyways
as long as you have Ubuntu and that
little Linux environment everything
should be the same
we will be using visual studio code to
edit things here jupyter notebooks will
be in the browser you'll you'll see that
later if you're not familiar with
Jupiter notebooks yet but
um just the premises that we'll be using
vs code as our text editor
and lastly before we jump into what Mojo
is
I want to say that for those AI
enthusiasts I'll begin with some simple
sequential cpu-based processing and then
later in the course we'll jump into some
still CPU processing but in parallel so
parallel is essentially or at least
sequential is when you do things one by
one you wait for one to complete and you
start the next and then parallel would
mean you do a bunch of tasks at the same
time so
we're going to start off with some
simple sequential based processing just
to understand the language because we
don't really need anything else to
understand the language we don't need
super high computational speeds
we're just going to need yeah just some
simple sequential we'll jump into
parallel processing later
so you might be wondering what the heck
is this whole Mojo thing maybe maybe you
clicked on it because Mojo is kind of
the hype right now but we're just
assuming you know you're completely new
to Mojo you don't even know what the
language is about what does it do
um so essentially Mojo is kind of like a
it quite literally is a superset of
python so you can use all the same
python syntax which a little bit of
limitations of course since it's a brand
new language
uh and you can get the the scale and
performance of a language like C plus so
you can use very simple syntax to write
the language and you can get insane
performance out of it so
why the heck do we need insane
performance well the thing with python
is that python is quite slow actually
python is not a compiled language so
python takes a long time and all of AI
research right now or most of it is
actually built and deployed with python
so all of the models that you'll see a
lot of the machine learning courses that
you'll see on YouTube and in other
places are purely based on python so
what is mojo exactly doing well it's
it's like python except you're getting
that speed where you're able to train
models or do renders way quicker
so imagine it taking you you know four
hours to get your model to a certain
prediction accuracy than with Mojo if
you were if you were able to optimize
around that and you know put a little
bit more effort into it you know some
key features that Mojo uses will allow
you to speed up the process and you will
essentially be able to train the model
in a fraction of the time so instead of
taking say four hours it would take you
maybe a few minutes if you do it right
uh so as advertised Mojo has insane
speedups over Python Meaning up to I
think 77 000 times greater uh 70 77 000
times faster than python in some cases
and that's
we're actually going to prove that in
this video we're going to actually walk
through and show how it speeds up and
I'm going to walk you through how that
all works but anyways this is a language
to sort of revolutionize the whole AI
space to make AI way faster to make
training quicker to make just
computation in general quicker through
language and the lower level
optimizations what I mean by lower level
is just closer to machine code
essentially higher level is like more
abstract closer to English and then
lower level would be closer to Binary
machine code so in case you haven't seen
the actual speed up that Mojo provides
we're just going to go into the
docs.modular.com I'll actually go back
here modular.com Mojo and then you just
click on the Mojo docs here
and then we can go to Mojo notebooks
matrix multiplication and then just roll
all the way down I'm going to cover this
material later in the course but just
pretty much scroll all the way down and
you can see that after a bunch of
optimizations they end up with a 77
000 X speed up over python which is
insane like that's almost taking an
entire day of python code running and
compressing it down into just a little
over a second that's crazy there are 86
400 seconds in a day and if we divide
that by 77 000
that means it's about
one one or or sorry 77 000 divided by
eighty six thousand four hundred
gives us that's zero that's 89 of a day
so before I even begin setting up I want
to emphasize that Mojo is a completely
new programming language was released
not even a few weeks ago
with minimal support on anywhere but the
GitHub or Discord so as for the Discord
server I'm just going to go to the the
modular Discord server you should be
able to find it through the the website
here
and essentially you sign up do your
verification or whatever and then you
can actually search errors so be like
you know uh error for example and then
it would give you you know a bunch of a
bunch of results so just search up like
specific keywords be smart about it uh
if you're encountering like certain
types of errors that are like really
long don't copy and paste the entire
error into the search bar uh rather just
look at like what are the keywords that
this that this error throws and then
just paste those in and just experiment
and see if anybody else has encountered
that because there are actually a lot of
people in this community if I scroll
down
2000 members so there are there's over
two thousand people in this community a
lot of which are actually offline right
now
but the point is there's a lot of people
that can definitely help you out and
some people that have already
encountered errors so you can totally
use the Discord to search for answers or
even ask answer or ask ask questions and
the other feature that you have through
Discord is if you navigate down to this
Mojo section and then go to Mojo bot
help they actually have an AI That's
trained on all of the Mojo documentation
so if you go at Kappa Ai and you say
um you know
what are
some basics of
Mojo
I could say
absolute beginner
and then it'll create a new little
thread here
and it'll say stand by for 20 seconds or
so
and in the meantime I'll actually show
you the GitHub so we go to github.com
modular ml
and this is everything really you have
the Mojo programming language here you
have a bunch of you know issues and
whatnot that you can submit to it what I
would recommend though is that you
absolutely make sure that if you're
going to be posting issues on this Mojo
GitHub that you make sure it's on fault
of Mojo because if it's your fault then
that doesn't really help out Mojo at all
because that was just how the language
was intended to work
but if you were able to verify and you
can verify through asking the Kappa AI
about your issues and even looking in
the Discord
and if you happen to come across errors
that are on fault of Mojo then you can
just go on the issues here and later in
the course I'll show you how to actually
uh post these errors and properly ask
questions so anyways those are some of
your sources for now there's a little
bit of stack Overflow but not that much
so your main sources are going to be a
little code issues
searching for answers using this Discord
search bar
and asking the Kappa Ai and the Mojo bot
help
so if I scroll up
says Mojo is a powerful language
designed for high performance systems
programming I'm sure similarities with
system languages like rust and C plus
but also designed to become a super set
of python
this means that many language features
and Concepts from python translate
nicely to Mojo Etc and it'll give you a
nice little summary it tells you how to
print stuff you can actually copy code
directly from it it tells you how to
make functions
uh
yeah essentially it you could just ask
it anything about Mojo and it'll
probably give you the best answer and as
soon as summarized form and yes you can
ask it to summarize things for you if
you don't understand a systems program
and concept uh you can definitely just
say hey Kappa AI summarize this for me
modular and Mojo only exist on Linux
machines or at least you can only
download them on Linux machines this is
a Windows machine but I'm going to use a
terminal and a Linux environment called
Ubuntu so in order to download that go
to Microsoft store
wait for that to load
move on to awesome search up Ubuntu app
and then
should be able to just install it there
when we open it
I'm not going to set up Ubuntu all over
again because I already have it so just
make up a username whatever and do that
whole process
um I'm going to go ahead and open mine
here so this is the current Ubuntu that
I have it's all signed in for me you can
do clear to get rid of things
uh you could do it LS to list it all the
directories that you have uh you can go
CD and then space dot dot to go back a
directory and then CD and then type in
the name of the directory you want to go
into and let's just look at what we have
so I'll CD into the Elliott directory
and you can just press tab to uh
autofill that
awesome so this is our Ubuntu terminal
so what exactly are we going to do next
well we have to make sure that we have
vs code installed that's also really
important so if you don't have vs code
go ahead and do that right now now
before we We Begin developing in the
Mojo programming language you're going
to pop over to extensions in vs code
here and then just simply go to Mojo
like that and you should see this
verified modular Creator and just going
to go ahead and install this this is
essentially the language support so
it'll be able to read Mojo files Mojo
files mean you can have this fire Emoji
which I'll try to
copy here
and
uh yeah essentially this this fire Emoji
I don't know where I can paste it into
maybe here
no that didn't work uh anyways
you can have your file extensions as
this fire Emoji or the dot Mojo
extension both of them work so that's
pretty cool uh Unicode characters for
file extensions gotta love it
anyways I'm gonna go ahead and close vs
code here and I'm going to make a new
directory I'm going to call it uh intro
to
I'll jump and I can CD into that so
you're going to go ahead and pop over to
developer.modular.com download and this
is just how you essentially get to
downloading Mojo So Go download now
and then says Mojo SDK is now available
awesome and here it says setup on
Windows Linux Mac Mac Intel well you
might be wondering why the heck did he
just tell us to only use a Linux
terminal Linux environment well the
thing is if we go to Windows it's not
available for Windows yet but you can
use it on the Linux container remote
system
you can use that with wsl2
we're just going to use Ubuntu for a
Linux environment same thing with Mac
right
not available for Apple silicon yet but
you can use Linux system
and then to install Linux there's no
warning there so awesome to install the
modular CLI you essentially just copy
this code here I don't know if the code
is different for different people but
you're just going to go ahead and copy
this and paste it into the terminal here
oh
okay awesome so it's newly installed and
then what do we do after this well we've
been let's actually check our modular
version so make sure it actually exists
so we have modular here and actually
another way of installing a modular is
to Simply go
sudo apt install modular that's a
different way of doing it if you'd like
to do that
um
but this way is more guaranteed I know
some people get
errors with the authentication key so
just just be explicit and put this curl
command
next up we're just going to need to
install Mojo So we go modular
install Mojo
we found a release let's install it cool
and then we don't need the rest of this
this is um already done
so I'm just going to close this out
and I'll come back when this is done so
to begin to run our first Mojo script
we're going to go ahead and open this in
Visual Studio code or vs code for short
and all you do is you just go code dot
period the period just says open in the
local directory so I go enter and we get
it to open up in vs code right here
so I'm not going to use this terminal
anymore I'm going to use the one built
into Visual Studio code so it'll do that
if you're on Windows you just go control
and then the grave symbol it's right
below the uh Escape key so awesome we
have this terminal opened up let's go
ahead and make a new a new file
so we go main dot Mojo and uh I'm just
going to zoom in on here
hopefully that's good enough
all right
I can it's cutting me off a little bit
awesome we fixed it cool so in order to
actually print hello world you might be
saying you know can we just do
can we just print out this way
and we get an error it says to do
expressions are not yet supported at
paloscope so file scope just means that
it's not inside of a function or a class
so this is not inside of anything except
for the file hence it being file scope
level so this is global and Mojo doesn't
like that right now so
to counteract this all we need to do is
just go FN main FN is short for function
that's what functions is what functions
look like in Mojo you just go colon like
that and then print
hello world and then if you really
wanted to
you could just do a variable here you
could go
let X or let's
hello equal
hello world
and then
you go in a print hello like that
Mojo
Main and so variables do work at file
scope but we're going to dive more into
that later but anyways we're able to
print hello world this is great so some
of you who use Jupiter notebooks might
be wondering well how the heck do I get
a Jupiter notebook running on my machine
and for those of you who don't know what
a jupyter notebook is it's essentially
just a giant notebook it's like a white
HTML notebook of a bunch of code that
you can paste into code blocks and just
run it in any order you want
so anyways you're going to see what that
looks like in a second and to do that
you're going to make sure python is
installed so make sure you go python3
version awesome
and then to install Jupiter just go pip
install
Jupiter just like that
so collecting Jupiter as you can see I
already have a lot of the dependencies
or requirements installed
so now we can simply just go
oh shoot there
notebook just like that
and should be able to open it up
right there
so as you can see this is what the
Jupiter notebooks look like and I can
actually create a new file
make sure that it's in the Mojo kernel
so you do Mojo and then you'll see it in
the top right here if you try to open it
up in the python
the Python 3 kernel then it will not
work
so we could simply just go
for example let x equals three and then
go ahead and print X
run that
awesome we get three and then if you
wanted to you could you could say print
X down here as well and you would also
get three so essentially everything
carries down from the bottom from the
top all the way to the bottom so you can
store some variables up here and then
just run them later down here as well
this is used for a lot of tools in data
science because or at least in data
science and training models you'll have
some you know trained model or something
you'll have spend a lot of compute power
on training a model
and you don't just want to throw it away
you don't just want to run a single
script and then just not be able to use
it ever again so you can either save
model files which is a bit slower and
you would do that with scripting or you
could use jupyter notebooks and just
save model parameters from a previous
code block and then reference it again
so that's essentially what this allows
you to do
and then I'm just going to delete all of
these awesome so this is our uh notebook
right now this is what it looks like so
you can choose to code along with the
notebook or not I will be using vs code
so I'm going to go ahead and close this
here
uh I'm going to exit in order to cancel
it you just go Ctrl C like that
so that's how your Jupiter notebooks
work I'm just going to right click
delete enter
awesome so that's Jupiter notebooks for
you now we're actually going to jump
into
how the Mojo language itself actually
works so now let's actually begin with
some variables so what are the different
types of variable declarations that
exist right now so there's let which
essentially is declaring the variable a
constant it cannot change
in in programming terms it is immutable
immutable cannot mutate it cannot change
it
VAR means it's it can change so let is
constant VAR is not constant so varlets
allows variables to be changed
hence it being VAR for variable meaning
it can vary
uh and then we have Alias which
essentially just uh compiles it stores
the variable at compile time
so compile time is when it's converting
your code to Binary form and runtime is
when it's actually just like running
code itself so if you have variables
that are sort of compile time you might
save yourself you know some some
nanoseconds or milliseconds whatever it
ends up being so most commonly you would
end up storing what we call libraries
with Alias but we'll go into libraries
more later
so we have let Varan alias
so if we go you know let x equal three
and then we were to
print out X
go Mojo like that
and we get a A3 here awesome what if we
were to change X to 2.
we can already see a red underline there
it says expression must be mutable in
assignment
so this x must be mutable meaning it
must be able to be changed when we
declare it with let that means it's a
constant it cannot be changed so if we
change the slides to a bar
then boom we get a two
so awesome and then if we were to just
go uh alias
it must be mutable in assignment so
alias
is essentially the equivalent of let but
for compile time rather than run time
so
far is specifically for runtime and it
allows the argument to be it deems the
argument mutable
and uh
let deems the argument immutable but it
goes at runtime whereas Alias would be
immutable at compile time so awesome
that's essentially just all the variable
declarations and information you're
going to need so next up let's go ahead
and jump into data types so I'm just
going to specifically use the let
declaration here we're going to go let X
and then you put a colon after
and there are a bunch of different data
types that currently exist so you can go
you can use a string you can use an
integer
you can use a floating Point number or a
float
you can use a Bool
you can use a
unsigned integer and we'll go over what
that means
and that's that's pretty much it you
have these These are the five uh common
data types that we're going to be using
there's one more that we're going to
introduce later
uh but these are the basic data types
that you're going to be using so what is
a string well a string good so we want
to declare it explicitly a string
and we let that equal
and all we would do is we would put
either some single quotes or double
quotes around it or even these ones but
I don't think it likes these ones very
much so we're just going to stick with
single and double quotes
I like to use single quotes because you
don't have to press shift when you're
pressing the quote button just it's just
easier that way and you don't have too
extra quotes to see through anyways
uh that's that's enough about quotes but
essentially you could just put whatever
you want in here any word I could
literally put one two three and
it would just say one two three but it's
in a string form so it wouldn't actually
be like the number one two three it
would just be like I guess the word One
Two Three or the string one two three if
you will
uh so that's strings for you you could
put you know you could put alphanumeric
symbols in it like like a question mark
or like like a Pam symbol or a percent
whatever you want
uh so that's what strings look like
next up we have integers
so integers are any counting numbers I
guess I guess you could say that so
accounting number would be like
pretty much negative one to infinity or
negative 1 0 1 3
462 or something right
um
so integers are any counting number they
don't have decimal places
and you can either say int equals and
then say like six thousand or you could
be explicit and say you know int 8
equals six thousand and eight means it
occupies uh eight bits on your memory
so if you actually want to calculate
what the highest number is that it could
store it would be two since it's binary
bits right and you do 2 to the power of
8 which is 256. so this could
essentially store uh 256 different
numbers on it
or 256 combinations if you will that
goes all the way from 0 up to
it goes from zero all the way up to 255.
so instead of 1 to 256 it would be 0 to
255 so just shift it over one but it's
still the same amount of numbers so if I
were to do 6000 in here it would
actually uh
it would not print that out it would it
would actually overload our into Data
quite a lot
so if we were to lower this number to
say you know 60 then we would get that
to properly print out some other uh int
bits I like bit occupying I guess you
could use is n16 there's an n32 and an
n64. there is no int 128 though so you
just have 8 16 32 and 64.
awesome and then if you don't want to
put any any number after it it'll just
default to N64 for for safety purposes
uh so next up we have the I'm going to
go over actually this this uint next
because it's very close to the integer
so U ins
if I can type
you end we'll just go eight for example
I don't think you can leave it just like
that unknown declaration must require an
explicit variable declarations so that
just means we have to put a number after
it we can go either eight uh 16
and 64. so same as int
and essentially U and what does the u
mean well the u means unsigned so if we
have a variable say
so we have an integer it could be you
know negative one zero one right that
would be an integer can be negative
numbers or positive
and a uint would just be an unsigned so
it cannot have a negative or positive
sign and when we normally write out an
and without a sign say like 60 we assume
that this is positive if we go 60 you
know plus 30 we're assuming that both of
these numbers are positives because they
just don't have a sign on them
um so that's what unit means it just
Only One Direction it can only go
positive whereas the int just int
without the u could also go negative
so so do your range for like an INT 8
for example would be uh 255 to negative
255. uh we can actually type that out
here
255 and we could print this out
oh it's going to go to negative one
if we go 254 Maybe
there we go okay so yeah 256 different
ones I got a little bit messed up there
but if we were to put
say
negative 256.
you would also get a zero as well so
that kind of just shows the range there
and you go uint
and
uh I just don't think that would work so
if you were to go like
maybe negative one
I wouldn't like that so I just default
to a positive number so that's what
antonuent are just signed an unsite
enters
and then next we have the floating Point
number so a float is just a decimal
number just imagine like
60 is an integer and then 60.01 would be
a floating Point number just a float
and to declare these we just go
we have to actually write a little
number after it how many bits it
occupies if we're going to be explicit
about it
uh if you weren't explicit you would
just go let x equal you know 3.14
3.14 and uh if you want it to be
explicit about it
you would just go colon
float and then you would put however
however many bits you want so you can't
go eight but you can go 16
and 64.
so if float 16 is just a essentially uh
like a half Precision number if you will
just lower Precision it's commonly used
in machine learning for training models
with like less numbers in them so float
16 is quite useful and a lot of Mojo
cases but anyways don't worry about that
too much that's just what these
variables look like or these data types
rather
and then the last one that I like to
show
here go ahead and print that go to 3.14
and then some little error there I don't
know why that is but that's that's
something on the Mojo end that we don't
have to worry about
um
but yeah now we have Bool which is the
last one
so we just do
ol just like that and we assign it to a
pool is either a true or false variable
so just go true we have to make sure we
have a capital first letter so it's case
sensitive
or we can go false if we were to type
like 3.14 it would say oh
cannot convert float literal to Bull so
it's thinking that this is uh it's
thinking that you're trying to put a
float here and it's like we don't allow
that we only allow for true or false so
a pool can either be true
or cross if we were to say print that
out
you get false
so awesome that is all of the basic data
types let's move on
so a lot of people that come from
languages like python JavaScript or C
plus or just any other language really
you might be asking why the heck aren't
you covering arrays or lists or
dictionaries
so the reason is because they simply
don't exist yet in Mojo I'll show you
kind of a little bit of a cheat way to
make an array but it's not quite the
same
but simply arrays just don't exist yet
in Mojo that's something that they're
working on right now so I can't really
go over that because it doesn't exist
but anyways uh what we're going to jump
into next is
how to get a user input and then just
print that out for example because
that's what a lot of you learned in
Python an introductory python course is
how to get a user input and then print
it out
So currently the simplest way to do that
is to go
we're going to import the python Library
you could say go python from python
uh
import python just like that make sure
the p is capital
and then inside of this FN Main
or outside of it rather you have to type
a raises I'll go into more of why raises
is needed later on but you just need
that to be there for now don't worry
about it
and then we're going to go let's
we're going to go let's pi equals
python dot import module and then we
would go built-ins
just like that
so essentially we're just importing the
built-ins module with which comes
default in Python if you were writing a
python script you wouldn't actually need
to import built-ins because it's already
done for you it just exists as a part of
python so you don't really need that but
in Mojo we need to explicitly import
this
and we're just going to give it a
variable name py
awesome so now we can go let some say
user input
equals Pi Dot input just like that so
inputs exist as a part of the built-ins
module inside of python so we could just
call input directly on that
and then we could say
um you know
what is your favorite
color
let me go ahead and print out
user input
say it
your
favorite color is
go Mojo
what is your favorite color
let's say I like green
your favorite color is green cool so
that's how you get user inputs in Mojo
use the assistance of python which is
a little bit funny but that's currently
how you do it right now in Mojo so
that's pretty cool so now we're going to
jump into if else statements so what the
heck is an if out statement well
it's simply if a condition is met then
you execute some code and if it is not
met then you default to some other code
and I'll show you exactly what that
looks like right now
so inside of our FN main I'm just going
to set a variable X
we're going to make it let's just say an
INT we're going to make it an INT 16 and
we're going to set that to maybe 100
okay
so now we can we can actually do the if
statement we could say if
X which is what the variable name is and
then double equals you might ask why are
we doing a double equals well double
equals because we're doing a comparison
so if we do a single equals up here we
are assigning uh the value 100 as an
integer 16 2X
we're assigning the value 100 to integer
16 data type
2x to the X variable if you will
and all we're checking is that if the
value of this x is equal to a hundred so
this should actually just
should go through so any code that you
actually put under this you have to make
sure that it's indented same thing for
like functions I didn't cover that
explicitly before but you do need to
make sure that you have indents so that
Mojo knows what to
uh essentially how to interpret your
script
so we could print out huh
true
that
wait wait get true awesome so if we were
to change X to say 101
we just wouldn't get anything it would
simply just say oh this condition is not
met uh this this little block inside of
here is not equal to true
so in other words essentially all if
looks for is if whatever this little
block of code or that whatever this
comparison is if it does not evaluate to
true then just skip it and and if it
does evaluate to true then we just print
whatever is indented inside of the if
statement so if you were to
say to else
this would be the defaulting that would
occur so you would print
uh
failed
and you would get failed because it says
this isn't true so we're just going to
default to else
if this is true
and then else if it's not then just
default to whatever is indented inside
of this else little block here
and the last one which you may or may
not use is called alif let's go LF just
like this and we could do another
comparison if x equals 102.
then we would print
same X is 102.
so it's still a hundred it's not a
hundred and one it's not 102 so it's
still going to go to failed but if we
change it to say 101
then we would get true if we change it
to 102
we would get X is 102 and then of course
if you wanted to add more of these lfs
you would only have an if and then an
out at the bottom
but if you wanted to have like a bunch
of alifs in between you could totally do
that so go L if x equals say 103.
X is 103 like you could totally do that
you can have as many LS as you want in
here but it does start to get redundant
after a while
so that's that's essentially how if L if
and out statements work if you're
wondering like what the heck does LF
mean that's just like a blending of the
word if and else so it's like taking the
first two letters of L and then
you know the word if so LF
um
awesome so that's your if statements
let's go ahead and jump into Loops next
so next up we have loops so what the
heck are Loops well there's two types of
Loops so there's
there's a for Loop and a while loop
a for Loop will typically execute
iteration by iteration until something
is met until an end goal is met whereas
while would just go on forever until
something is met so 4 would typically
stop somewhere whereas while would just
go on forever until some conditions are
met
uh
so let's actually start off with a for
Loop and a lot of you python people have
probably
seen this exact sort of form before but
essentially we go for index or four uh
iteration for iteration
and in short we could just say 4i
because it's less characters to type and
we'll just go 4i in and we would go
range and you could put any number here
I'm just going to put 10.
and then you put your colon indent and
we're just going to go ahead and print
out I so this is what a basic for Loop
will look like
shouldn't it clear this
and we get numbers printed out from 0
through 10 or 0 through 9 sorry because
it starts it actually starts at zero and
then goes
you know one by one until it until it
satisfies you know a range of ten so ten
different numbers there's a zero all the
way through nine so if you were to shift
that over one through ten
um
so anyways that's what for Loops look
like and
I'm going to go more into how we can
like play around with these later I
actually might do it after this Loop
part but anyways next up you have while
loops so
what do while Loops look like
well it's sort of the same thing as an
if statement it looks for a condition
being true so we could say you know
while
or
while X is say less than 10
we could go
X plus equals one and we would just
maybe declare X since it doesn't exist
yet let's say Lex or let X and then we
would say maybe an integer say being
into eight
uh and eight equals zero
uh must be mutable so we have to change
that to VAR good catch
uh while X is less than 10 we would do
this and then just to you know make sure
it's working properly but just print out
X if I run that
uh it'll print out I just oh
it would print out one through ten so
it'll start at zero it'll add one two x
so plus equals you could also do you
know minus equals or multiply equals or
divide equals
uh
we're just going to do plus equals for
this instance and
that'll essentially just add one to this
current value here so it'll add One X
will become one then it'll print at X
and then we see that's why we see the
one first so it looks for until this
condition is met until or while X is
less than 10 once it becomes equal to 10
then we stop so
uh X is therefore equal to 10 then we do
this last editor and then it cuts off
and then also what you could do is
you could just put it true in here and
then go
uh you put a little if statement inside
of it saying you know if x
if x is
say greater than or equal to 10.
we would break
so what does break do break is
essentially like extremely simple it'll
just stop the loop so if you put break
inside of any Loop it'll just stop it
and we can actually print this out over
time so we go
print X
and we would get the same behavior so
Loops are a little bit more complex but
that's essentially what you have is you
have your for loops and your while loops
so I'm actually going to show a little
like array I guess thing you could say
with loops and all we're going to do is
we're going to let X
we're going to make it equal a python
object
so in order to do that we're going to
need to actually import python up here
so from python
import python object
and we're going to set this equal to say
an array so we go 2 4
6 8 10. an array is just a list of
numbers wrapped in square brackets and
then each of these numbers here is
assigned to an index so 2 would be index
0. everything starts at zero in arrays
so
to be at index 0 4 would be at the next
one
six would be at index two eight would be
uh three and then ten would be four so
if we were to
say you know print X at position three
uh oh
why are we getting this cannot call
function that would raise okay so
we're gonna have to add braces in here
again ignore the raises for now but uh
essentially this this is a python array
and we're just printing out the third
index of it so zero one two three
zero one two three
and then it a three is equal to eight so
we get eight the third index is eight so
we get eight sorry
um so that's what that's what arrays
look like and we can iterate over these
using a for Loop because we go four I in
range and then we could just say
I'm going to say 4i in X for example
because X is actually the array itself
so we go 4i and x and then just print
out I
oh
I guess we can't do that we can maybe go
range and then
length go
x dot underscore
length and then under Splinter score
maybe that'll work
okay yeah
so we could go uh X at position I
and then we would be able to print all
those out don't worry about this too
much this is just me taking some Python
and transferring it over to Mojo this
little length thing this Len uh is just
a short short form for length and then
you put these around it because that's
the that's the method that it calls but
don't worry about this at all this is
just porting some python stuff over to
Mojo and it it's still being like mostly
python so
don't worry about this at all this is
like not part of the course this is just
me playing around with stuff
but anyways
now we can actually jump into functions
so you might be wondering about
functions and if you've done Python
Programming before you've probably seen
this def uh this def function so for
example def add numbers you pass in two
function arguments uh A and B
you let c equal to and that the sum of A
and B and then you return whatever C is
so if a were to equal 2 and B would
equal five you would say uh C is equal
to a which is 2 and B which is five so C
would be seven and then you would return
seven which is C
so uh that's what python functions or
defs look like and in Mojo they're
actually quite close so be an FN short
for function and then you would put
whatever your function name is you would
wrap it in these round brackets
you would pass in your function
arguments and we'll go over these in a
second here and how you can put function
arguments into it from like actually
calling the function uh and then you
would put whatever you're going to
return inside of uh like outside of
these uh round brackets so you put an
arrow and then whatever The Returned
data type should be
so in this example we go you know let c
equal to uh
an integer and that's equal to a plus b
assuming these are both integers from
here
and then we would return C which would
be again an integer because that's what
the specified data type was and then
since we know it integer we would return
as an integer data type so
sort of a that's that's the main
difference between Mojo and python is uh
FNS or FN functions are more explicit
whereas defs are less explicit and they
would take a little bit more time
because
um that computer actually has to like
understand what you're doing rather than
just having you know the rules just like
hard to find and just like full steam
ahead
so
that's kind of the difference there and
uh so what we could do is actually go
ahead and call this function so I'm
going to go FN Main
well passion no function arguments in
here and I'll just go
add numbers same
let's
X will that be an INT
we'll say add numbers and we'll go ahead
and pass in
say two and five
and then if we were to go ahead and
print out what x is
we should get seven just like that so
let's actually walk through step by step
what's happening here because to an inch
like
newer programmers this might be actually
quite scary to look at
so the reason we put add numbers above
here actually if I were to put it below
you might see that
uh does it still work I should actually
double check that okay I guess it does
still work so you can have your
functions in any order top or bottom and
Mojo will be aware of where they are so
you won't need to have something above
it for Mojo to recognize that it exists
um we'll just go ahead and put it back
there though because that looks better
so you have this you have this function
add numbers you have a parameter a which
is an integer type it just defaults to
N64 because we don't tell it how many
bits to occupy
and then you have a b as well which is
also an INT we say that this this
function is going to return an integer
type or an N64 type
and we say let's see let C be an integer
data type
meaning this is a constant
C is a constant integer 64 and it's
going to be equal to whatever the
integer A and B are equal to and then we
would return C whatever the value is
that's what you would return from the
function so you call a function it does
some operations and then the function
returns a value to its caller so the
caller in this case would be in our F
and it would be on our main function so
this add numbers is the caller here we
pass in two integers two and five
we make sure that this is a constant X
integer 64.
uh
and
then we would we would essentially just
have the output of that so X would be
equal to whatever this function returns
which would be seven and then we could
just print that out so
that's essentially how functions work on
the explicit level when you're explicit
about what variables you're using then
that's how that works so we could
actually like replace all these ins with
int 8.
and then here as well you could go int 8
and everything be the same we're going
to jump into a concept called object
oriented programming so object oriented
programming is concerned with these
things called objects or classes or
structs whatever they happen to be
called in the programming language
and
anyways I I'm not going to philosophize
about it I'm just going to jump right
into it so
uh the best way to really compare this
is to look at what do they look like in
Python and what do they look like in
Mojo so I'm going to create a new file
called main.py and this is what an
object would look like in Python so just
clear this drag it down
so what's happening here
we have a class called a banana
um
actually I'm not going to go through the
class first so initially we have if name
equals main it'll essentially just run
this main function just it's just it's
the way that Mojo works when you call
this main by default it's the same thing
going on here it just calls the main by
default
so this this main function is going to
create a banana instance it's going to
pass in a a bunch of arguments here and
then we're going to print some attribute
about this banana so what does this
banana look like
well
we have an init so in it it you could
think of it as a Constructor it makes it
actually initializes the banana clasp
so
what are we actually passing in here
well we have self is required we have a
ripe attribute
which would be Boolean so true or false
a length which would be a float in
Python
and a color so a string and these are
these are just things that I picked out
sweet
ripe could be like you know a floating
Point number if you want to put on a
scale for example but these are this is
just what I'm working with
um
so in the in your init or in your
Constructor you would say uh self you
would say self Dot and then all the
attributes for example self.ripe would
be equal to this this ripe argument
self.length these are just the variables
of the actual class itself that's what
the self dot whatever it looks like
and then you have length and color
so these are all the variables that
we're initializing for our Banana class
and then if we were to
say call The Ripe attribute on
on banana
like we do here
it would essentially just return
whatever ripe is so we have a def ripe
um
we pass in self as a function as a
function argument because it's a def
it's a def function
and then we're returning the Bool value
so
we return self.ripe which happens to be
a Bool so we return Bool here
uh
and then we also have say a length as
well I'm actually going to add the color
in because I didn't add that in yet so
we go uh def go color
self and then we would return color
which is a string so go Str
and then we go return self dot color
awesome
if I were to print you know banana which
is our we've created an instance of this
object so you can have as many objects
as you want
and they have a bunch of different
attributes and you can just call those
attributes
um
so we go banana dot open out dot save
like color for example
and we would just go python3 main.py
it's going to print out banana.ripe
which is false as we passed in and then
yellow because the typically the color
of bananas are yellow I don't know what
type bananas you eat maybe you eat red
bananas but
uh anyways that's that all works out
nice and smoothly so uh if you want like
feel free to pause the video and just
try to like conceptually make sense of
what this class looks like because these
are very important classes and objects
and structs are essentially the basis of
all languages
except for languages like C which don't
have them but uh so in in Python this is
what your object would look like and
this is just a banana object for example
so now we're going to jump over to what
does this look like in Mojo So let's
compare this side by side here so in
Python we have a class banana in Mojo we
have a struck banana
in Python we initialize our variables
with an init method uh self and a bunch
of arguments in here with their
corresponding data types and then here
we initialize our variables with self
Dot and then whatever the variable is
equals whatever the parameter goes
passed in there
you could also do like lowercase that's
fine too but I just find uppercase to be
more consistent and it's like easier to
read
especially for classes I I don't know
some people like to do it differently
but that's just what I'm doing in this
case
so in Mojo you would actually Define
your variables here you would say you
know what the variable name is and you
would say what data type it is you don't
have to declare uh really what it's
equal to but just that it exists it has
a name and what data type it has
and then you would have your init method
here as well I'll go into this in out
little piece here in a little bit but
this is not in the basics of the chords
this is a little bit after
so uh you you get the idea it's sort of
the same arguments in here uh you have
yourself ripe length color
uh self-ripe length color
uh awesome and then they're declared
literally the same way as python in this
like this block of code is equal to the
same as this block of code
um
and then for our little methods here so
you have or rather functions inside of
the class
you have a you have your FNS instead of
defs
ripe and then you would pass itself
because that's self is essentially the
object itself so self is needed in
objects and then we say rhs because rhs
is equal to right hand side and this is
on the right hand side just it's just
kind of a common practice you could say
like value or or something else but it's
commonly just seen as like rhs that's
that's typically what it ends up being
someone in in our death ripe we pass in
a self and we return a pool uh
and then we actually return the bull
here so this is like what type we're
going to be returning and then we return
the actual ripe
um
variable if you will
here we'd we also have this right hand
side so we we pass in uh the banana
itself and then we say
we're gonna return a bull type and then
we return this this ripe which is up
we'll type hence returning pool here
uh and then it's just kind of the same
same thing it's a pattern for the rest
of it so as long as this one makes sense
as long as this init method makes sense
and these variables make sense
everything else below here should as
well and in order to actually create an
instance of this banana yes you can
create multiple instances
you would essentially just give it a
variable you say VAR or let a banana
equals and you would call this struct
and you would pass in what variables or
what arguments are required so you have
a ripe which is a bull so we'll just say
false let's say the banana isn't ripe
um
and we give it a length maybe it's 4.7
centimeters long the float 32. and then
yellow which is a string so we have a
banana that isn't ripe 4.7 centimeters
long and is yellow
so cool that's how you create an
instance so you can actually go like you
know for our
I can't type banana two and then you
would just you would you would
essentially call this banana struct and
you would pass in whatever arguments are
required so
hopefully that all makes sense and if we
want it to say return the ripeness of
this particular banana instance
then
you would just go called banana dot ripe
so this particular banana then you would
call The Ripe function on it the right
method
and you would pass in banana to it so
this would ultimately return
uh
oh let me try this up
banana was declared as a VAR but was
never mutated consider switching to a
lead so it's just giving us a warning
and saying oh you're never really
changing this instance so you may as
well just set it to a constant because
variable is
is a mutable or not constant so we could
save let and that would resolve that
warning
so awesome
we return banana.ripe and we get false
so cool that's what objects look like in
Mojo versus python so hopefully that
hopefully that is super clear now if
something didn't make sense totally feel
free to uh pause the video look back
play it on half speed even chat gbt your
way through it because that's honestly
how a lot of people learn nowadays and
it is a pretty good way to learn as to
at least with these basic concepts is to
just plug it into gpd4 and say hey I
don't understand this or if you you have
a particular question about maybe the
init method like why is it called why
does it have two of these underscores
around it right
you could pass that into chat CPT and
say hey why why is this why is this a
thing and then I would hopefully be able
to help you but as for Mojo specifically
uh
chat gbt isn't really trained on it
because its cut off was 2021 so your
best bet would just be to go to the
Kappa AI in the modular Discord and just
ask it that way
so that's what I would recommend if you
don't understand something is to just
ask the Kappa AI
um anyways let's move on so before we
actually jump into importing libraries
modules just other people's code in
general uh I should let you guys know
that inheritance uh inheritance exists
in Python
uh essentially if you don't know what
inheritance is essentially it's imagine
you have a a class and it's an animal
you have an animal class and you have
like a dog cat or a dog class and maybe
a cat class maybe a giraffe class okay
you have a bunch of animals
and then you have this one main animal
class so typically what you would do is
instead of writing all of the dog cat
and maybe giraffe classes from scratch
you would inherit some of the attributes
from the animal class so you'd have some
like General variables and
some general things to find in the
animal class and then you would inherit
those uh in the uh in those other
animal classes so like the dog cat and
giraffe so that way you wouldn't have to
write a bunch of code that way so you
would just inherit and it would be less
work for you and essentially this is
actually how a lot of games work so if
you have like you know different enemies
uh typically you would have like an
enemy class and the enemy would have
some attributes like when you touch it
or when you get hit by it then you take
damage or
you can do damage to it
or they you know they they only spawn in
uh danger zones or whatever it is and
you would have you know a bunch of
subclasses that inherit from that
initial enemy class that would say oh
these are some things that are
describing uh each different unique
enemy but it also has these General
attributes that all enemies have
so that's just what inheritance is and a
general overview but it does not exist
in Mojo yet unfortunately so we are able
to create classes like these and pass in
attributes to them but we cannot
actually use inheritance we cannot
inherit from other classes yet in Mojo
that does not exist so anyways let me
get rid of this here and we can actually
begin to import some libraries we're
just going to import one
so we're going to import from python a
lot of the libraries here we're going to
just import them from python so we could
go
from python
uh oh not capital I import
python just like that
and then we record an uh F and Main and
we would need raises here and I figure
this is a good time to tell you exactly
what raises does so raises essentially
you need to include it in functions that
could potentially raise errors so if you
were importing a library from python say
like numpy for example uh some of you
might be familiar with numpy and
sometimes you might get errors importing
that or at least you might get little
underlined saying oh what if this messes
up what if the library doesn't exist but
we're still trying to import it well
then you would just say you know the
function raises what raises means
because it can raise an error the
function is capable of raising its own
error aside of Just The Interpreter and
compiler so uh this is just super useful
I'm going to go more into depth into
raises and all of these errors and
exception handling a little bit later on
but essentially it's just to say we
might get errored out but don't worry
about it too much because we're sort of
expecting it in a way
um
so we can go ahead and uh
you could just create we could just
import numpy here so we go let's numpy
and then oh not that python
import module and instead of built-ins
like we did before we can go uh numpy
just like that and then we can
essentially create arrays with numpy so
we go let's array ARR for short for
array numpy Dot
array and then we would put our array in
it so maybe you know one four nine
16. a bunch of squared numbers
uh and then we could just
say print
square roots
uh
now we don't have to do that we could
just say
print array
times two
and then we're just going to Mojo Main
dot Mojo
and
1 times 2 2 4 times 2 is 8. 9 times 2 is
18. 16 times 2 is 32. so we actually get
that returned in the numpy array form so
that's essentially just how you import
modules in libraries as you would you
would do from whatever and then import a
certain you know sub object or whatever
and it's it's very similar to python as
a matter of fact it's like the syntax is
the exact same except your the libraries
just look different when you're
importing them
uh and then to actually import it from
python you would do this python.import
module and then whatever it's called so
if you're going to import tensorflow you
would put
you would put tensorflow here
if you were to put numpy you would do
just as we did before and Etc
so uh later on in the course I'm
actually going to show you how to create
your own packages so uh so instead of
just importing them from somewhere else
on the Internet or somewhere else that's
like downloaded a part of your mojo but
you didn't create it
I'm going to show you how to create once
and then use them so that's a cool
little feature that modular has been uh
super you know easy going about I guess
it's it's just really easy to make your
own packages in this language and in
this whole modular framework thing so
I'm going to show you how to do that a
little bit later but for now let's just
jump a little bit more into what exactly
does raises do so in Mojo we use four
error four words for error handling so
as you've seen before we use raises and
raises is
uh essentially in any function that may
raise an error needs to be explicitly
marked with this as we went over before
it's part of Mojo's error handling
semantics uh so oftentimes you're going
to use this when you're importing other
libraries because it may or may not work
right you may have an error there
um but most of your errors will be
raised automatically by the compiler and
interpreter so don't go like out of your
way to just include raises in every
single function if if you are getting
little underlines like red underlines
like errors uh just try to include
raises and then see if that changes
anything but you shouldn't need to
explicitly include raises in every
single function
um so that that's what raises does you
put that after the round brackets of a
function to essentially say this might
raise an error
um and then this try try accept and
finally all go together
so I'm actually going to paste in
some code here that I've gotten from
before so we have a function main raises
so it might may or may not raise an
error and we just explicitly declare
that
and then we have this try so what does
try do
try will attempt to run some code
for example open a file so let's say we
have some input.txt file over here and
we're trying to open it and maybe like
read the contents inside what try will
do is it'll maybe we'll try to open that
open that file we'll try to open it
we'll create like a new resource for
example and then open that file with the
resource
and then accept will
look for an error say a file encoding
issue say our file is like has some
corrupt data in it the encoding is messy
for example uh and accept will
essentially just catch that error and
say hey uh we found something and then
here's a little error reporting on what
it was about if this code fails so it'll
attempt to run it if it's successful
it'll just go all the way through in
this except block will not be triggered
but if there is an error then
this will still finish
and we'll get a we'll get an A little uh
what we can essentially raise an error
so we can do raise instead of raises
we just do raise and then error because
we're raising an error right it kind of
converts to English easily that way
uh and then you would just in round
brackets put whatever your error
reporting is so you have an error number
you would go like
error number one zero three nine or or
whatever you do
um
awesome
and then this finally is very important
in some cases not as important in other
cases but
I'm just going to use an analogy for
this
so imagine you're trying to say
uh open you're you're trying to open a
microphone resource here so this
microphone that I have right here let's
say I want to just use it with like Mojo
or something even though it's not
supported yet
um
imagine we're trying to open this
microphone and we're trying to record
something so we attempt we attempt to
open the microphone resource and then
say we get an error with like maybe
there's something wrong with the
microphone who knows
um so we get an error it says
something's wrong with your microphone
fix it
but what this finally does is instead of
just stopping at this error and then
terminating the code finally we'll
instead uh still follow through whatever
is inside of it whatever this indented
code is inside of the finally block
so
if we were opening a microphone we
probably don't just want to leave it
hanging we probably don't just want to
have it you know go on forever and just
essentially leak the microphone right we
don't want to be leaking that resource
at least to other errors that you don't
want to deal with
and essentially finally just says I got
you covered man we're gonna
we're gonna take care of that so
typically and finally you would just
essentially close that resource so
we oh we attempt to open a resource we
say it fails instead of stopping there
we stead we instead guarantee finally
guarantees that we actually follow
through with whatever this code is and
there we could close the file instead of
having memory leaks or resource leaks so
finally is really useful there if you're
taking advantage of resources but if
you're just trying to you know attempt
some block of code and then you see if
you get an error see if it faults then
you wouldn't really need to finally
block for that finally it would just be
you know when you need to run something
even though there's an error that
happens
so that's kind of how that works that's
that's pretty cool uh very good for
debugging of course if you're trying to
if you if you think your error is in you
know some piece of code then you would
put try around it and then if it errors
out be like oh so that there's some like
specific thing wrong with my code it's
in that section and then you can debug
further
um
but yeah if we were to Instead try to
close the file after it errors out if we
were to Instead try to close it down
here
uh that wouldn't work because this code
isn't guaranteed to run once you uh once
you post it once you raise this error
uh essentially nothing else other than
finally is allowed to execute code so
you raise this error and then
immediately it says we have an error we
cannot execute whatever this is but
finally says we're guaranteed to execute
this no matter what so hopefully that
clarifies the whole uh error handling
exception thing uh
what we're going to do now is we're
going to go ahead and move on to some of
these function arguments like in outs
and some other ones that you may or may
not have seen before so what the heck
are these function arguments you speak
of well function arguments could be one
of many there's like quite a few I'm
meaning like three or four in this
language
and the first one I'm going to cover is
called in out
so what this means we we already went
over function so I'm not going to go
over that again but essentially when you
mark a function argument within out it
means that that argument is mutable or
changeable
and changes made inside of the function
so meaning changes made to for example a
we pass it in as a equals 4 and then
we mark it with n Out
um and we change it to three then that
change would also be visible to
everything outside the function so I
highlight the words inside and outside
because that's what in out comes from in
and out changes made inside the function
are visible outside and out
and then the next one is called borrowed
so let me go ahead and copy I've
borrowed code in here
not really borrowed I created it but we
use this label or called borrowed and
this essentially just labels these
explicitly immutable meaning you cannot
change them so if we were to say to Mojo
Main dot Mojo
um
we initialize a a and b so we have a
four and a five we call add nums on
those uh
and let's say we were to try to change
it to
uh let's see if we're to change you know
a equals three and then b equals two
well why are we getting underlines
expression must be mutable in assignment
okay
so what if we change it to
in out for example
and out
because argument zero must be mutable in
order so argument zero is essentially
the first one it's catching the error on
the first little function argument here
uh
in order to essentially run our code so
uh notice that we've declared with let
so if we change this to VAR
then
everything works so we set a to 3 and b
to 2 we get five
um
but if we were to say set these two
borrowed
then this wouldn't work because these
these initially are variable meaning
they can change they are mutable and
then we explicitly label them as
immutable meaning you cannot change them
and inside of the function
so
Express expression must be mutable in
assignment so essentially that's what
borrow does it says this belongs to the
other function and we're not allowed to
change it even if in the other function
you say that it's a VAR or variable
um
so yeah that's that's uh in out and
borrowed for you and the next one I'd
like to cover
is
uh owned owned is an interesting one
Owen will essentially say with with
whatever variables we've labeled here
that those variables now belong to this
current function so for example even
though we uh initialized uh these
variables as immutable using the let
declaration
uh when we pass them into here using
owned it says okay now this function
owns them so we can do whatever we want
so this essentially takes off that
little immutability feature and says we
can do whatever we want to them and if I
go ahead and run this code
uh you'll see that so now these actually
belong to this function and they are now
mutable
so uh if I were to say you know
something else like
if borrowed
then that wouldn't work because we're
taking it we're taking it from this
function here
if I were to even go
like that it would say
expression must be mutable because we're
initializing it as let over here which
is immutable
we're trying to change it even though it
cannot be changed so essentially own
says
um
it's just explicitly saying that this
this current function which owned is in
uh we can do whatever we want with that
variable this function now owns it
so the next statement that I want to
cover is called with so the with
statement you may have seen this in
Python before but like especially in
Python width is typically used to open a
file so in Python you would go
um so with open here we go input.txt and
you would go
right
or read sorry and then as F you would go
say text equals F dot read
and then we would print out some text
if I were to create an input.txt
say
you know peekaboo
maybe we go in
run this main file and it would open
this in read mode as F or file and we
would read the file put that in a
variable and then print that variable
out
so essentially What's Happening Here is
with is acquiring a resource meaning
files right we're acquiring a file read
maybe a write resource
and we want to make sure that after
we're done with the resource that we
dump it so we're going to open it we're
going to use we're going to use some
file reading and writing resource we're
going to do some code we're going to do
something with it and then we're going
to close the resource afterwards
um this isn't this isn't too common with
Mojo yet it doesn't really doesn't
really exist doesn't there's essentially
nothing you can really do with it right
now
um so I'm not going to worry about that
at all you might be asking what is the
difference between with and like a try
except finally block
well the thing is is that with
uh by default isn't really going to
uh run some code no matter what so
typically in the try except finally you
would attempt some code you would
potentially throw an error and then you
wouldn't do some stuff after so
um I'm not my awareness of the whole
with statement isn't like too in-depth
but uh I know there's there's definitely
some differences there in terms of how
it compares to try except finally versus
just with so you could actually look
into that on your free time but we're
not really going to be using with in
this course at all so don't worry about
it
so next up I want to cover something
called variable scope so in Mojo you
would typically see like you know let's
say x equals three and then you have a
FN Main
and you would say maybe y equals say let
y equals four
so
this is a concern with something called
variable scope so variable scope is like
you just have a variable and then what
is the scope of it so this one would be
file scope since it's in the file
everything else in the file can access
it if we were to go ahead and print X we
would get uh
we will get an output there so we this
uh this is included in all the functions
so all the functions can access like
file scope or interchangeably
Global variables file scope and
Global scope variables are pretty much
the same thing
and
whereas this let y would be specifically
in the function so if I tried to
uh
you know if I had a different function
to
I don't know who I would show this but
essentially this is
specifically only accessible to this
function only so there can't be any
other functions that can access y so if
I if I said
um
if we had another function say
FN
print y
uh
and then I work to
you know say
print y we return that
uh come on let me just keep that
all right move this up
and then
we were to say
Maybe
print y will return
whatever Y is whatever Y is equal to so
it'll say unknown Declaration of Y uh
require explicit variable so essentially
saying that y cannot access this y
because this Y is specifically in the
main function so therefore other
functions cannot access it so this is
what we call local scope
so local scope just means it's like
defined to a specific function or a
specific struct or something
um and that's essentially what variable
variable scope is so if you've worked
with python before you've probably
experienced some errors with variable
scope
um but anyways that's just essentially
saying you can't make a variable in a
function and then call it in another
function without like passing in the
argument of it so
that's what that is
now let's move on to some of the tools
with the Mojo Mojo command line
interface or the Mojo CLI
so if you pop over to the Mojo modular
documentation here and just scroll down
to the Mojo CLI and go to yep you could
just essentially click on maybe just
click on Mojo
and you'll see that essentially this
Mojo thing is actually a command line
interface in and of itself so we've seen
that we can call Mojo files or we can
run Mojo files with just the Mojo
keyword and then pass in whatever file
you're running very similar to python
you can use modular to of course update
Mojo but modular is not really the focus
of this it's more like Mojo command uh
commands
so Mojo run
built and executes a Mojo file I won't
be really using this much because it's
not as important
but what is important is this little
build command here and this will
actually accelerate your speed by quite
a bit not by like 5 10x I mean it might
but it honestly depends on what you're
doing
anyways let's just cut to the Chase and
I'm going to show you what build does
let's actually use this Mojo build
command so I've I've just ported some
code that I've written to essentially
test uh Pi torch on both CPU and GPU so
we went over sequential processing and
parallel processing uh this is
essentially just doing that and we're
just comparing speeds so uh you don't
this this is probably scary to look at
at first but essentially if I do uh
Mojo Main dot Mojo give it a second
Cuda
okay
and we get a CPU time
a lot of this time is spent actually
importing the packages itself
so now some of this is going to be spent
you know so some of it is going to be
spent on Cuda time as well so CPU
actually performed almost 5x better than
the Cuda time which is insane
and if I wanted instead build if I want
to instead build this into a binary form
and then run it which should be faster I
would just go Mojo build and then main
dot Mojo just like that
and we should see main binary file
pop-up in order to run this we would
just go uh dot slash
dot slash main
we can say we get a Cuda 1.2 seconds or
sorry CPU 1.2 seconds and Cuda is sped
up by quite a bit so this sort of just
proves that normally running Mojo in
this way is less efficient or less less
quick rather than
making a bill uh making a binary file
using the build command so if you're
just testing around and playing with
things in Mojo you shouldn't really need
to build it but once you're ready to
push it and like really like see what
the limits are of of that file and just
see like how fast can this possibly go
then you would want to use the build so
if you're pushing something to
production or you just want to you know
say in the future you're able to train
some neural network and you want it to
go as fast as possible you might want to
use the build command rather than just
running it normally
so anyways that's how that works it's
fairly simple you just build this and
then you do dot slash and then whenever
the name is in this case it's main so uh
awesome that's how that works now we're
actually going to go into how you can
build your own package so for example
python is we're able to import it it
counts as its own module or library or
package whatever you want to call it and
we're just going to create our own we're
going to create some object or class or
struct and we're going to import it into
a different script even though it exists
on a completely different place on the
computer so I want to build a package
just to use to maybe use later and so
first of all we're gonna have to go to
the docs I skipped ahead a little bit
there but essentially you go to Mojo
uh and then
I might full screen this for a second
or just CLI and we go to Mojo package
and then
uh so there's a whole description here
about just like some extra options you
can pass into it but what we really care
about is this see more about modules and
packages so let's go ahead and click on
this I'm going to drag this over to uh
like a split screen and we're just going
to follow the instructions
so provide the packaging system that
allows you to organize and compile code
libraries into importable files so when
you like import python for instance you
go from python
import Python and then you can use some
of the built-in libraries it's
essentially like that except we're big
we're making our own libraries
uh introduces necessary Concepts blah
blah blah and to understand you don't
understand motion modules so single
source file that includes code suitable
for use by other files that import it so
you can create a module to define a
struct such as this one so let's go
ahead and follow along I'm going to go
ahead and uh actually we're going to
scroll down just to make sure we have
this structure correct because there's a
structure down here that we're supposed
to follow
uh so we go make a new directory we call
it maybe uh my package
and then we make a new file inside of it
we go init
.mojo and then we make a my
module
dot Mojo awesome and then we have our
main here it's awesome these are all
empty what do we put in them next
so we have this my module.mojo here so
we'll just
pop this in and let's let's first look
at what this does this is a struct uh we
have some we have some variables uh two
integers essentially we're just making a
pair hence it being called my pair uh
you those those are essentially just the
the instance arguments that we're going
to pass in when we call this with our
package
so awesome now what
now we have a main dot Mojo so we're
going to have to actually import
from this we're gonna have to go my
package
you're going to see this a crash happen
in the Mojo parser so
I can actually go ahead and run this
main dot Mojo and it we're getting
aborted this is currently still
something that Mojo was figuring out
right now I was running into this error
quite a little bit and we're just gonna
sort of Go full steam ahead and we're
gonna go to the end result that we
actually want we're not going to be
concerned about this for too long
so
for example import something that's in
the same directory so so essentially
what's happening when we import this
we have from so it's going to come from
somewhere else so it's going to come
from the my package directory dot my
module so it's going to come from my
package dot my module and we're going to
import my pair
so that's exactly what this like quite
literally what this says from my Mac
from my my package.my module import my
pair and so this should work fine and
really all we have to do to fill in the
blanks here is essentially just create
we're going to create a package out of
this and you can leave the init.mojo you
don't have to edit this at all
so essentially uh how this goes is we
just go Mojo
package and then we look at whatever the
name of this package is called
save my package we're going to do Dash o
and then whatever name we want it to be
just be like maybe
test pack
oh testpack dot Mojo package and you
have a nice little Unicode character
here as well which is really cute so
just a DOT Mojo package file extension
and we can go ahead and create that and
we see that it shows up here
so in order to actually import this into
our main dot Mojo now we see that it's
in the same directory it's in the same
local directory as
main dot Mojo So these are together so
we don't need to like import from
something you know far out
all we can do is essentially just
go
from testpack.my module because keep in
mind it's still going into this my
module instead of my pack but this is
just compressed into like a shorter form
so if we go ahead and run main dot Mojo
now we should see
uh main dot Mojo we get two and four we
passed in the pair two and four and we
get that output so that's that's really
it that's that's honestly how you make
packages just uh you make sure that you
create a directory in the local folder
and then you put an init Mojo it has to
have two underscores on both sides and
then whatever your module name is called
and then you do whatever you need to in
here maybe a struct maybe a few of maybe
a few structs if you want
and uh that's that's pretty much it so
that's how you create packages so we
just covered two of the command line
tools that Mojo uses so Mojo build and
Mojo package so uh if we want to
actually look at some others you could
just go down to Mojo here and we we can
see that we have
we have run build which we already did
uh repl that's not something I'm going
to cover in this video we just did
package formats I don't think this is as
important uh docs I haven't seen a lot
of usage with like deem angle dot format
a little bit of Rebel but uh just just
for like the basics and creating your
own packages and building a binary
executable files build and package are
going to be your Best Bets if you want
to you could totally dive into
other commands but those are the only
that I feel like are very necessary for
the basics uh anyways you should give
yourself a pat on the back you made it
really far and there's actually only a
few more Concepts we have to cover
there's there's not that much you're
like almost done so give yourself a pat
on the back grab some coffee or whatever
you do and let's jump right back into it
so I want to introduce the coolest data
type ever it's called a simdi so what
does simd stand for what is this Cindy
what does it mean well simdi is short
for single instruction multiple data so
that means you can have say an array and
instead of doing an operation on each
element in the array
you just do one on everything so it's
only one operation
so what does this actually look like if
we were to say use python
so in Python you'd have like an array
say maybe you know two four six eight
or two four
and essentially you would have to Loop
through this entire array and do an
operation date element let's just say
we're multiplying by two so you have to
go through each element you'd go to the
first index you would you would set the
new you set a new array to equal
uh what is this times two and then what
does this times 2 and then what is 6
times 2 and then what is 8 times 2 you
would do all of this sequentially
but Sim d
is different so you can just do times
two one time you multiply the entire
thing by two and it's done
just like that in one operation it's
essentially a CPU instruction so
it's it's a it's an easy way to write it
but essentially CPUs accept a certain
type of instruction or the CPUs will
accept some instructions that will allow
them to take like shortcuts and
loopholes around things so 70 is an
example of that where you don't have to
iteratively multiply or add things
together you could just do it all at
once in one operation
so for example if I were to print say x
which is the 70 and then I
multiply by 2.
I could run this and we would get
essentially everything multiplied by two
and this all happened in a singular
operation
so
next up there's a there's an interesting
uh
I guess method you could say we could
call on
the 70 type which is len so Len is
equivalent to
essentially length of x
in Python that's what it would look like
but in Mojo we would do x dot when and
then
so just some round brackets
so this will print out four because we
made the length of it four and this is a
good time to actually delve into what
each of these parameters are so first of
all you initialize a variable say let x
equals
and then
we could just say it's equal to a single
instruction multiple data data type and
then we have some square brackets here
and inside of these square brackets
you're going to pass in the data type
that you desire it to be and the length
of this multiple data if you will
and
so to do that we use D type and then dot
whatever you want it has a this this
data this data type needs to have a
lowercase letter so you can't just do
like float 16 it has to be a lowercase
letter
um and then this uh this four is
essentially just how long it's going to
be because it's one dimensional it's
just like one dimension so after these
square brackets you just have these
round brackets here and this is the
contents of what you want and there's an
interesting thing we can do with these
because consider these this is four
elements here and we explicitly declare
that this is going to be four elements
long
so what happens if we add a fifth in say
25. and then we print out what is X
multiplied by two
we get uh this number we get this Sim d
uh returned back so this essentially
means that we're going to take the first
four numbers of whatever you put in here
and then everything else we're just
going to splice It Off
so that's a cool little feature I don't
know if that's a feature or a bug but
I think that's pretty cool how you don't
get errors for doing that so
anyways there's a lot of operations you
can do with these uh you can there's
certain ways to make like a really long
uh
what we call Vector that's just the same
exact number all the way through
um
and this actually leads me into
a little bit more Deep dive of what this
Sim D type is so let me go ahead and
just uh
get rid of this and I'm going to copy
some code in oh
so
we have a function add and we have a
function main no no don't get scared by
this too early
so what does this function main going to
call well we're going to let x equal the
same D type float float 16. it's
literally the same one we just used and
we're gonna we're gonna pass it into a
function called add so x and x
so what's actually happening in this add
function well
first of all
we have some uh we have some square
brackets here this is going to determine
uh what the data type is and what the
length is so these are the two uh
essentially needed
function Arguments for operating with
simd types so
you would essentially give a name for
what the data type is so D type we would
give that data type
and then the lengths we would just set
that to the data type int we could it
could be like an in 32 and 64. it
doesn't really matter we're just saying
that's going to be an end here so this
is like converting your data types to
names that we can use later
now we have these round brackets and
notice how oh notice how these actually
stretch out quite far
so in here we specify the actual
function arguments themselves what is
this first X going to be that's going to
be a that's going to be this piece right
here so a is going to be a Sim D type
with data type D type and length of type
integer
and then same thing for B here except we
can't just we simply can't have a twice
because that would that would give us
errors so we're just going to do a and b
so
next up we have uh we're essentially
just returning
what this is what this entire function
is going to return which of course has
to be a simdi type with a data type D
type and integer so
that's that that's a lot of content but
essentially all that really happens is
we just add them together it's a single
single operation that we do and if I go
ahead and run this here
we will get uh this we could even we
could even multiply them together
can even multiply them
one times one four times four nine times
nine and sixteen times sixteen we could
even divide them if you want since
they're a float float 16.
so
everything divides by itself or if
something divides by itself it's equal
to one so that's why we have ones there
but anyways these instructions are super
cool I'm not going to dive like an
insanely amount I'm more into them but
we're going to use sim D types A little
bit later on to do some speed tests but
before we jump into that I want to cover
some other uh Concepts and topics
the next one being decorators and meta
programming so I've just kind of
implemented it it doesn't really do
anything but this is what it looks like
this is called a decorator
and
decorators come from a practice called
meta programming where meta programming
implementations look at the code
architecture you've attached the
implementations to and have the code
optimize itself based on the specific
meta programming feature you're using so
uh in the context of unroll essentially
what this does is it unrolls the loop
you have some Loop and it unrolls it
into a bunch of individual uh iterations
if you will so if we have if We're
looping over this 10 times if we're
doing I 10 times
instead of going sequentially
it'll split it out into 10 different uh
individual Loops that it'll uh
individual iterations that it'll do
um and so we can even pass parameters
into unroll
we could go for example uh two and what
two would do is it would split it into
iterations of two and loop over five
times so there's a bunch of ways that
you can mess around with these meta
programming features they make
everything super hackable hence the word
meta programming it's it's a beautiful
word
and this essentially allows you to take
advantage of maybe parallelizing some
operations maybe you have a loop where
instead of sequentially running it you
want to split it into a bunch of
individual iterations and then plug
you know say a fraction of them into
each processor that you have and have it
done in a fraction of the time
so little optimizations like
optimizations like this will greatly
help performance but meta programming
has always been sort of an advanced
feature so I thought I'd share with you
uh what exactly they look like and an
example of what one of them does meaning
unroll but they are an advanced feature
so I'm not going to go super into it
this video however if you are interested
and wanted to dive deeper into
decorators and meta programming I would
highly recommend that you refer to the
documentation so let me now show you the
case for an up to 77 000 X beat up over
python it's blown a lot of people's
minds in the past little bit but so if
we just go to the modular documentation
here
uh just docs and then Mojo notebooks
matrix multiplication and Mojo just
scroll to the top I'm not going to walk
through like the actual Matrix
multiplications going on the algorithm
here isn't important
a fact of the matter is is that we just
need to plug these code blocks in and
see how it progresses based on what
features we add to it and what
optimizations we add so what I've done
is I've ported all of this code block by
block
all N2 and you can see they have a 77
000x speed up and I've ported all of
this into my own notebook here
so I've already run everything and as
you can see uh initially we get you know
0.001 gigaflops and then after an
optimization we get a 0.01 gigaflops
which is an 8X speed up
and then like everything here is uh
compared to the original by the way so
everything is compared to the first
three code blocks
so we get an 8X beat up and a 3000x
speed up
and I'll go into what exactly well what
exactly is making it go up to 3000x
and then a 13 000 X
a little bit more
and then at 22 000x
and then 19 000 just due to some
Hardware stuff it could go up or down
depending on your Hardware
um
and then it just kind of settles around
a 20 000 X beat up and this is just for
my machine again mode uh the modular
team probably tested it on a machine
that was favoring this code that they
used so there might be other ways to
optimize around your own Machinery but
that's not something you should worry
about as a beginner all you should worry
about is what are the fundamental uh
what are the fundamental concepts and
practices you can use to get the most
significant speed up without over
complicating your entire thing so if you
can get like a 5000x speed up and it
takes you five minutes to implement it
maybe just stick with that maybe you
don't even have to go to
you know a 10 000 X beat up because
that's just that's just making it twice
as efficient it's not as big as a uh a
5000 x jump so anyways I'm gonna walk
through this uh sort of what's Happening
Here
so initially uh we're using python to do
a matrix multiplication and the thing
with python is that it's not very good
at running code on multiple CPU
processors so if we actually look I can
check my current CPU processors if I go
to
uh performance we go to CPU and it'll
just say logical processors here or your
threads logical processors and threads
are used interchangeably
so you can see what your number is there
and that's essentially how many
processors can do computations in
parallel
so initially
python is only using one of those 12
threads
and
then what we do afterwards through uh
through this next jump let's take a look
and see what it's doing
so what this appears to be is instead of
using all python we're actually jumping
over to some Mojo syntax so we're using
FNS and we're being uh more explicit
about what types we're giving things
we're being more explicit we're getting
more to the point about what exactly the
code is time to accomplish
and then
I'll just navigate back here because
it's hard to follow along when
everything is black and white
so initially we use One processor
and then we use some modules from Mojo
and we use some Mojo based kind of
syntax we do some importations here
uh
then what
then we add types okay
so yeah just just adding types in is
going to give us significant speed up
and then
and then we have a benchmark function
which is built into Mojo and it's used
to just sort of do speed tests like
these do benchmarks
so
now we get into the the cooler stuff
that I actually enjoy talking about
so one is vectorizing what the heck is
vectorizing
so imagine you have uh you're you're in
a I mean some of you have probably taken
introductory physics before or something
close maybe a science class and so when
you think of a vector you think of a
direction and a magnitude a scalar is
just a magnitude but Vector has a
Direction with it as well
so for example
um if you were if you were say had a
velocity maybe you'd be going you know
10 meters per second at this you know
amount of this this amount of degrees
right so you'd have some direction and a
speed at which you're going in that
direction so that'd be a vector
so some ways to actually store that
would be maybe an X attribute so if you
have a you have your little hypotenuse
here you have an X attribute and a y
attribute so you have your X as one
in your in your zero with index and then
you have your y attribute in the first
index and then you have maybe your
um
maybe your direction in the
uh
in the second index and if you wanted to
increase the dimensionality of this
meaning if you wanted to instead of just
have two Dimensions you would go to
three so you're having vectors in 3D
space or you could just increase it up
to like 10d or 100d whatever you wanted
to and essentially vectors are ways to
describe uh
essentially Direction and magnitudes in
it any dimensional space so with
vectorizing we essentially convert
things to the Sim D type and this allows
us to do these Matrix multiplications
with far less operations so I was
talking about the simdi types before and
we're essentially just treating our
vectors as some D types and then working
with those
so that's what vectorizing is converting
to something that you can do one
operation on that's going to scale up
computationally wise
and we can see that we get an insane
speed up there so 1600 all the way to
7000 so we've just sped up this a ton
just by using vectors
then what's next
so parallelizing so you might think
parallelizing has to do with the GPU but
in this case it doesn't actually what
parallelizing does is instead of just
using one thread we're going to be using
maybe not all 12 but pretty close like
maybe 10 or maybe eight of them or maybe
11 who knows we'll be using a lot more
of these threads or logical processors
essentially in parallel so imagine you
have a giant piece of data and you have
you know four processors that can go
through it so instead of having one
processor or each of them go through the
same amount of data just from from the
start all the way to the end what you do
instead is you give them each little
jobs so the first processor can do the
first quarter second processor second
quarter third processor third quarter
and Etc
you split it into jobs and what ends up
happening is everything is run at the
same time all the processors are run at
the same time and each of them complete
uh their jobs at the same time because
these lists are or these pieces of data
you have to sort through are now a
quarter in size in comparison to the
entire length so now you've just
essentially decreased your total run
time by a quarter just by having four
processors that you're running things on
So based on the number of processors
that Mojo is allowed to access this is
governed by the operating system and
some other features I'm not going to get
into
but essentially that's what
parallelizing is is splitting a task
among a bunch of processors instead of
doing the entire thing on one
so with parallelizing we go from 6800
all the way up to 62 000. so in this
case they probably had a lot of
processors that were being utilized to
get this 10x speed up compared to uh
about 6000 x beat up
uh and then the last and then the last
one that's quite interesting is called
tiling
so tiling and tiling is an interesting
one uh the best way to sort of
conceptualize this is to think of a
giant grid of numbers like a giant two
by two like a times table if you will a
giant two by two times table and instead
of calculating everything all at once
and this this might not be like a 10 by
10 times table this might be like a a
500 by 500 times table or even way way
uh larger than that
so what piling allows you to do is
instead of uh doing everything at once
and drawing it from your RAM your slow
memory it will cache it in your CPU your
CPU has little RAM chips that are way
higher bandwidth and they allow uh
information to be transferred almost
instantaneously
so
what this allows you to do is
essentially load in little bits of this
times table at a time so you can do
computations on them so say you want the
first you know five numbers one two
three four five one two three four five
so you've got a you've got five times
five there you've got essentially 25
boxes that you're gonna do instead of
say 2 million or 2.5 million or there's
some crazy number and you can load these
into your caches your CPU caches
preemptively so you don't have to do
this right away or else that would that
would essentially degrade away at your
runtime constantly having to move things
into your cache and then use them that
just adds on to extra time
so the compiler could be smart and
instead of move over what it knows it's
going to need before it has to use it
and then once it's actually asked to do
those computations it can like very
quickly draw from that little cache uh
and then get the next one in so that's
it's ready to do the next computation so
this way you're saving time uh from
avoiding that giant delay and drawing
all of that information from your RAM
and rather just having it ready in your
CPU caches
and to look at those
we can see our CPU caches we have an L1
L2 L3 so your L3 would be the slowest L3
would be or sorry L2 would be a little
bit faster than L3 and then your L1 is
like extreme speed like this is almost
incomprehensibly fast and so probably a
lot of these uh this tiling operations
are going to be stored on your L1 L2
maybe L3 cache
so that's kind of just what what what's
happening with uh tiling when we do
matrix multiplication it's like storing
times tables in little uh tiles
essentially
hence it being called tiling and that
way you're saving the memory uh draw
time the transfer time
so
that's vectorizing
parallelizing and tiling for you so
hopefully that all made sense if it
didn't totally chat GPT your way through
it man I totally encourage you guys to
use generative AI to help understand the
stuff better it's such an amazing tool
but anyways
that pretty much sums up uh everything
that's
this course covers so
bear with me I'm going to do a little uh
outro here with some more little facts
and stuff that you may want to know
about the language and so next up I'm
going to walk through how to report
errors and actually before you actually
report any errors there's a lot of
things you have to check over first
so one
uh actually just go to the Mojo bot help
and then type you know Kappa AI I have a
problem and then it'll open up a new
thread and you can ask it questions just
by tagging it through the at symbol
so Kappa AI is essentially memorized all
of the Mojo docs and knows everything
about modular so you can just bombard
your questions with it it's not a human
so there's that and then also being able
to search through errors through this
search bar this is a huge help so what
if I uh say like environment
variable
and then I get a bunch of uh I can go
new old or relevant and get a bunch of
data about how do I read environment
variables in Mojo right like there's a
bunch of comments here so you might be
able to find your error maybe someone
else has already ran into it and they've
gotten an answer
or you can collaborate with somebody
else in this Discord server so this will
be in the GitHub repository and also you
want to make sure I'm going to go to
github.com
go to Mojo and
if you're actually looking at an error
what you want to make sure is that you
check issues because there's a lot of
errors that have been asked here there's
actually like a lot of pages of errors
so what you might want to do is just
take a quick scroll through these and
just look for any keywords say you know
maybe I can't access
environment variables and you go to the
next page
and then nothing is found here right and
you keep going through your pages and
just look for your keyword essentially
to see if that and if anybody has ran
into this problem before and to see if
it has been answered
so that way you're not just bombarding
this whole issues issues page with the
same error twice
because if you have the same error twice
then that means they have to you know
it's that's a little bit of a hassle for
the modular team and you don't want that
because you want a good programming
language faster so just be cautious
about that it shouldn't be too hard to
look through and just see if errors have
existed yet just look through the GitHub
look through stack Overflow look to the
Discord server ask the Kappa AI and then
your last resort is probably going to be
if it's at fault of Mojo So if it's not
your fault it might be Mojo's fault and
it's something that nobody has asked yet
and you actually need to
propose an error or a question
so
a few key points that are very important
when you're asking a question
so you need to be specific so clearly
State what you're trying to achieve uh
where you're facing issues secondly you
want to show effort indicate what you've
already tried so include some relevant
code or error messages so you want to
have full information be respectful so
you want to be polite and appreciative
because these are other people that are
taking time out of their day to
potentially help you so you want to just
be respectful and sure that you care and
aren't just trying to
care only about yourself
you also want to use descriptive titles
because when these developers and
debuggers are going through and they're
they're looking at all the titles they
want to be something that's easy to read
something that they can make sense of if
it's like
you know just a bunch of random
characters it's like hmm maybe that
person doesn't quite know how to ask
about errors and so that's going to be
harder for them to approach because they
don't know what's going on
uh so you want to address the issue or
question within your title
you want to keep it relevant so stick to
the main topic and avoid any unnecessary
details make sure everything is
formatted properly I'm going to show you
how to do that in a second here how to
make sure your code and logs are
formatted properly
you want to also include some system and
platform details so since this is closer
to a systems programming language you
want to include some information about
your system such as maybe your RAM maybe
just some other aspects that might that
might affect the reason you're getting
an error so anything it could be
remotely close to that you want to make
sure you have full information once
again and lastly avoid emotional
language don't get mad don't don't swear
uh
so just just be super polite about it
and don't get like mad or anything I
mean we're all developers here we're all
on the same page we're trying to Make a
Better Community for the development of
artificial intelligence systems so uh
don't get mad just
take a chill pill if you can and uh yeah
so anyways I'm going to walk you through
how to actually submit errors so here
are some examples of both good and bad
examples so
if you're on GitHub and you're trying to
propose an issue you go new issue you
say title a bat a bad example would be
software
keeps
crashing dot dot dot and then
your software sucks
fix it
am getting
compiler
getting compiler error so first of all
the title is misleading it doesn't
really give any information about it uh
it's a little bit disrespectful because
you're not considering uh what it looks
like from their perspective
your software sucks that's like you
don't need that fix it it's hard to know
what to fix if you don't give any
details and getting compiler error well
you need to spell things correctly first
of all and
uh just getting compiler error could
mean anything there's like billions of
compiler errors that probably exist so
uh don't go down that route instead uh
what a good example would be
would be
um
unable to save settings in version at
2.1.4 so it's showing like a version
specifically that you're getting errors
in
um and then just something around saving
settings and then
maybe your body would look something
like hello first of all thanks for the
great software so you're like oh this
software's great you're being polite I
recently updated to you know version one
two three or two one four and notice I
can't save my settings anymore every
time I click save the software crashes
and then maybe you would provide
um
maybe you would provide some steps to
reproduce so uh you know open software
go to settings change any setting click
on save so this way that developers can
reproduce the error if other developers
are able to reproduce your error then
it's easier for them to pinpoint where
it's going wrong because if it's working
normally for everybody else and not you
then if you can show a way where they
could get the same thing as you then
they can compare what's working to
what's not working and try to mess with
things in between to get to a breaking
point where it works and then doesn't
work because of maybe one line or
something so that's really useful and
then what your expected result maybe it
was right to I mean expected result you
don't always need to put it there but
it's still a good practice
then your actual result is you know
whatever error you get some system
information as well like maybe your
operating system for example if you
tried to install mojo on a MacBook and
you didn't have the Linux terminal if
you just use the Mac terminal of course
you're going to get errors because it
doesn't support Mac OS yet so system
system information is always good to
have
um and then just you know be polite any
help would be appreciated thanks
so that's a wonderful example and even
if you wanted to you could also consider
uh maybe just putting some quotes around
things so let's say steps we produce
um
you put three quotes around it
like that
and
uh we should we should when we submit
this issue I'll actually go
just to show you guys what that looks
like
so when you put the three quotes both on
the top and bottom of something then you
get this
and then if you put single single quotes
we're talking about uh these things by
the way not these not these just the the
grave
and essentially those those quotes are
going to
allow you to make little code blocks in
here that people can copy and paste from
um so this takes a little bit of
practice you can create your own GitHub
repositories and practice it on your own
but this is generally what it's supposed
to look like it's supposed to be very
clear you would probably include your
logs in the form of this and then maybe
some code that you have in the form of
this like where your line is uh erroring
out so since Mojo is kind of an AI
derived language it's used for
accelerating a lot of these artificial
intelligence systems through just faster
Computing so a big question is is since
it's so early a lot of people are
wondering if you can actually build and
train neural networks in Mojo so I can't
really say yes or no to this but if you
were to use something like say
tensorflow
um that wouldn't work quite or
tensorflow or Pi torch that wouldn't
work quite as well because uh you depend
on a lot of things like file read and
writing inheritance maybe Lambda
functions arrays whatever which just
doesn't exist yet
um
so technically if you want to go the
easy route and use a lot of the Python
libraries that wouldn't work however
there are still some people uh building
some pretty cool projects right now that
are more like a lower level uh like they
kind of look like C plus plus code a
little bit so they're
not as pythonic if you will and I'll
actually leave a project like that into
the in the description somebody actually
was able to uh
build or at least attempt building the
lamma2 model using Mojo
so that's cool that's just going to be
in the GitHub repo in the description so
feel free to check that out
uh the other point is that since we
cannot read and write uh to files uh
there there would be no point in
actually doing a lot of this training so
we would have to rely on third parties
like python to do this read in writing
and saving the actual model files for us
or else what's the point of even
training right if you have a script that
trains a model and then just dumps all
the parameters after then I mean you've
maybe used it one time maybe you prompt
the model once but that's just a lot of
wasted computation so we want to be able
to save the model files so that we can
use them again and that's just not super
compatible with uh plain Mojo right now
so
my answer right now is like no for
beginners you should not attempt to
build any neural networks from scratch
or anything or even use pythonic
Frameworks so for now my answer is no
um
and I should probably add to that
meaning like what doesn't exist in the
Mojo language if neural networks don't
really exist
they they kind of do but they also kind
of don't
um what doesn't exist yet so you have
list comprehensions like arrays
dictionaries
Etc you have Lambda functions from
python those don't exist yet struck
inheritance uh you would see something
like this with pi torch and inheriting
an N dot module if any of you have
worked with pi torch before so you can't
really keep track of your gradients that
way and then again file read and write
does not exist yet so uh there might be
a few other things that I maybe didn't
cover but those are kind of the
the the huge ones the outliers that are
uh really important that you should know
about
and then lastly if you are really
curious uh
I would honestly just consider reviewing
the roadmap which you can find at uh the
modular website if we actually head over
to the modular docs here
you can go to
roadmap and sharp edges
and you have some priorities here so CNC
plus plus interop protocols traits just
just a bunch of uh cool things here to
look over and stay up to date with so
now you should have all the tools in
your belts to actually get started with
you know reading Mojo documentation
building your own projects playing
around with the language and all that
fun stuff so I hope you enjoyed the
video this tutorial was designed as a
sort of beginner uh emphasizing for
beginners people transferring from
Python and trying out mojo as well as
just some you know Concepts that you
should be aware of when you're doing
more advanced systems programming so
hopefully this tutorial was informative
to you hopefully it helped my YouTube
channel is in the description below so
if you didn't want to check me out and
maybe even subscribe that's I mean it's
totally free you can unsubscribe later
but I make pretty good content on there
so uh you might want to go subscribe uh
that's just in the description so
anyways that's all I got
have fun my fellow magicians